bravant les coteaux spécialité vins de
chinon appellation contrôlée
la commune compte 600 hectares de
vignobles qui fournissent 45% de la
production viticole totale du chinonais
les viticulteurs représente donc un
poids économique important pour ce
village de 700 âmes
contrairement aux agriculteurs et aux
éleveurs les viticulteurs n'ont pas à se
plaindre de la sécheresse actuelle même
s'il ne souhaite pas le clamer sur tous
les toits
un état de fait particulièrement
flagrant sur les coteaux des terrains
argilo calcaire qui ont retenu le peu
d'eau qu'il est tombé cet été
lavigne c'est une plante qui elle a
besoin de chaud et on ne peut pas se
plaindre que la vigne se passe mal voyez
vous il n'ya pas de mal a dit rien des
taux et
nous allons faire une récolte moyenne
c'est-à-dire pas tardive n'est pas très
précoce n'ont pu à peu près comme les 85
dans les graves
c'est à dire dans la plaine la situation
n'est pas aussi favorable
cet hiver lavigne a subi l'effet du gel
et 10 à 20% des pieds sont improductifs
aujourd'hui le manque d'eau dessèche
petit à petit les grappes
rien de trop grave mais la récolte
devrait en pâtir
ce sont des vignes qui ont qu une
dizaine d'années bon de par leur
enracinement elles sont pas très
profonde compte tenu que depuis deux
mois on n'a pratiquement pas eu d'eau en
dehors de 5 6 mm la semaine dernière et
depuis une semaine c'est vrai quelle
fatigue sérieusement de la sécheresse
alors c'est celle d'avoir une incidence
sur la récolte oui d'une part sur le
rendement et contrairement à ce qu'on
peut croire même en ce qui concerne la
qualité c'est pas pour ça qu'on aura des
degrés supérieures les viticulteurs de
cravans ne sont donc pas trop mécontent
du bel été 86 les vendanges seront plus
tardive sans doute qu'en 76 ou en 82
elles devraient commencer autour du 10
octobre
quant à la qualité du chinon 86
difficile de la comparer à celle d'une
autre année les vieux vigneron sont très
philosophe vous dire que ça ressemble un
damné ya aucune année qui serait sans
vraiment c'est comme les goûts on dit ça
vaut ça vaudra tel annette à l'année
c'est pas vrai il n'y en a pas une qui
se ressemblent et c'est ce qui fait
justement la valeur de nos bases il y en
a jamais inquiets pareil